if we don't bring inflation back down to  Target and we leave it at a point where  we don't have price stability  the situation gets much worse worse in  what sense well the economy becomes more  unstable  I think we would have much bigger  fluctuations and outputs I think we  would have much bigger job losses and at  the end of the day I'm afraid if we get  into that situation the action that  would have to be taken thereafter to  restore stability would be much larger  and much more damaging so it's critical  that we take the action so the pain is  necessary to prevent something worse at  that point but how does it feel Doling  out that medicine well it never feels  good I don't think anybody should think  that Central Bankers uh in a sense feel  good doing this but it is our job